reddit has exploded after the electoral
college victory of Republican candidate
Donald Trump now president-elect so much
discussion on our reddit discussion
forum now over 1,800 members please head
over and subscribe
it's obviously free whether you
participate or not I I would love for
you to participate but check out some of
the discussions going on there david
pakman.com slash read it real quick i
want to go through a few of the topics
that have come from our viewers over the
last few days after the election we had
a post about more crappy news nebraska
votes to reinstate the death penalty
they must have a lot of money for
appeals and axes to grind pun intended
and a conversation happening on reddit
about the death penalty
another post-election story on our
reddit discussion forum not being
mentioned enough today regarding
wisconsin and michigan
Bernie Sanders beat Hillary Clinton had
to get head in the Democratic primaries
in those states he would have beaten
Trump in those states and had a decent
shot at winning the presidency a lot of
people wanting to have this conversation
after Hillary Clinton's defeat in those
states also from our reddit discussion
forum Dave Ben you called it linking to
an article from a French newspaper
Lamond which points out that yes indeed
there are those who are linking
gamergate to Donald Trump's victory via
what we call the alt-right and indeed
that is an interesting article which you
can look at on our reddit and translate
from French to English it happened
gamergate linked to the Trump victory
and one more now that Mister word
randomizer won and this is sort of a
post on our reddit discussion forum that
we need to be really concerned about the
future of the United States after the
Trump victory and I won't read the
entire post to you I would love for you
to go to david pakman.com slash read it
and check it out yourself but this is
something that a lot of our viewers
patter are concerned by which is what
happens next how bad is it going to get
under Donald Trump
and I like that there's a place online
where our viewers can get together and
sort of discuss these issues I think
that question specifically asked what
will happen to Hillary Clinton and if if
she may need to move outside of the
country
yeah I'm fear being put in prison ending
by saying we need to start storing food
it's funny the food storage stuff is
usually the hallmark of the religious
right and now after Trump wins all of a
sudden liberals are saying are we going
to need to start storing food maybe I do
need to call Jim Baker in order 50
gallons of oats or something like that
we may need to start selling our own
bonus buckets yeah we're gonna start
having to really sell I'm into the bulk
mashed potatoes business I think we're
maybe instead of thinking of david
pakman show coffee we need david pakman
show dehydrated spuds or something like
that i mean you don't have to wait for
the apocalypse to eat them i'm sure
they're very good dried up in those
buckets yeah you can start eating them
right away